ANTONY BLINKEN, SPEAKING AT THE
U.N. GENERAL ASSEMBLIES.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DETERMINATION AND THE MORAL
CLARITY THAT YOU BROUGHT TO
ENDING THIS BRUTAL WAR AND
DEFENDING THE U.N. CORE
PRINCIPLES AN ALSO FOR YOUR
PERSONAL ENGAGEMENT FOR GRAIN TO
FLOW ONCE AGAIN FROM UKRAINE.
MR. KHAN, WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
EFFORTS FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
PROSECUTOR TO INVESTIGATE
OBJECTIVELY AND PROFESSIONALLY
THE ATROCITIES BEING COMMITTED
IN UKRAINE BY RUSSIAN FORCES AND
FOR ITS SUPPORT FOR AND
COORDINATION WITH UKRAINE
INVESTIGATORS AND PROSECUTORS.
WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE DIVISION
AS MONG COUNTRIES AT THE UNITED
NATIONS.
BUT RECENTLY WHAT IS STRIKING IS
THE REMARKABLE UNIT AMONG MEMBER
STATES WHEN IT COMES TO RUSSIA'S
WAR ON UKRAINE.
LEADERS FROM COUNTRIES
DEVELOPING AND DEVELOPED, BIG
AND SMALL, NORTH AND SOUTH, HAVE
SPOKEN BTS CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
WAR AN THE NEED TO END IT.
AND THEY'VE CALLED ON ALL OF US
TO REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT TO
THE U.N. CHARTER AND ITS CORE
PRINCIPLES, INCLUDING
SOVEREIGNTY, TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY, HUMAN RIGHTS.
EVEN A NUMBER OF NATIONS THAT
MAINTAIN CLOSE TIES WITH MOSCOW
HAVE SAID PUBLICLY THAT THEY
HAVE SERIOUS QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
PUTIN'S ONGOING INVASION.
RATHER THAN CHANGE COURSE,
HOWEVER, PRESIDENT PUTIN HAS
DOUBLED DOWN.
CHOOSING NOT TO END THE WAR, BUT
TO EXPAND IT.
NOT TO PULL TROOPS BACK, BUT TO
CALL 300,000 ADDITIONAL TROOPS
UP.
NOT TO EASE TENSIONS, BUT TO
ESCALATE THEM THROUGH THE THREAT
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
NOT TO WORK TOWARD A DIPLOMATIC
SOLUTION, BUT TO RENDER SUCH A
SOLUTION IMPOSSIBLE BY SEEKING
TO ANNEX MORE UKRAINE TERRITORY
THROUGH SHAM REFERENDUM.
PRESIDENT PUTIN PICKED THIS WEEK
AS MOST OF THE WORLD GATHERS
ATHE UNITED NATIONS TO ADD FUEL
SHOWS HIS CONTEMPT FOR THE U.
CHXT CHARTER AND FOR THE GENERAL
ASSEMBLY AND FOR THIS COUNCIL.
THIS VERY INTERNATIONAL ORT
ORDER IS BEING SHREDDED BEFORE
OUR EYES.
WE CANNOT, WE WILL NOT ALLOW
PRESIDENT PUTIN TO GET AWAY WITH
IT.
DEFENDING UKRAINE'S SOVEREIGNTY
AND TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY IS
ABOUT MUCH MORE THAN STANDING UP
FOR ONE NATION'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE
ITS ONLY PATH.
FUNDAMENTAL AS THAT RIGHT IS.
IT IS ALSO ABOUT PROTECTING AN
INTERNATIONAL ORDER WHERE NO
NATION CAN REDRAW THE BORDERS OF
ANOTHER BY FORCE.
IF WE FAIL TO DEFEND THIS
PRINCIPLE, WE SEND A MESSAGE TO
AGGRESSORS EVERYWHERE, THEY
COULD IGNORE IT TOO.
WE PUT EVERY COUNTRY AT RISK.
WE OPEN THE DOOR TO A LESS
SECURE, A LESS PEACEFUL WORLD.
WE SEE WHAT THAT WORLD LOOKS
LIKE IN THE PARTS OF UKRAINE
CONTROLLED BY RUSSIAN FORCES.
WHEREVER THE RUSSIAN TIDE
RECEDES, WE DISCOVER THE HORROR
LEFT IN ITS WAKE.
I HAD A WINDOW IN THAT WHEN I
TRAVELED TO IRPIN WHEN THEY
GATHERED EVIDENCE OF WAR CRIMES
COMMITTED THERE.
I SAW UP CLOSE THE GAPING HOLES
LEFT IN RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS BY
RUSSIAN SHELLING.
INDISCRIMINATE AT BEST.
INTENTIONALLY AT WORST.
AS WE ASSEMBLE HERE.
UKRAINE AND INTERNATIONAL
INVESTIGATORS CONTINUE TO EX
HUME BODIES OUTSIDE OF IZYUM
BEFORE THEY WERE DRIVEN OUT BY
UKRAINE COUNTER OFFENSIVE.
ONE SITE CONTAINS SOME 440
UNMARKED GRAVES.
A NUMBER OF THE BODIES UNEARTHED
SHOW SIGNS OF TORTURE INCLUDING
ONE VICTIM WITH BROKEN ARMS AND
A ROPE AROUND HIS NECK.
SURVIVORS ACCOUNTS ARE ALSO
EMERGING.
INCLUDING A PLAN WHO DESCRIBED
BEING TORTURED BY RUSSIAN FORCES
FOR A DOZEN DAYS DURING WHICH
THEY REPEATEDLY ELECTROCUTED HIM
AND BEAT ME TO THE POINT WHERE I
DIDN'T FEEL ANYTHING, END QUOTE.
THESE ARE NOT THE ACTS OF ROGUE
UNITS.
THEY CUT A CLEAR PATTERN ACROSS
THE TERRITORY CONTROLLED BY
RUSSIAN FORCES.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MANY REASONS
THAT WE SUPPORT A RANGE OF
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
EFFORTS TO COLLECT AND EXAMINE
THE MOUNTING EVIDENCE OF WAR
CRIMES IN UKRAINE.
WE MUST HOLD THE PERPETRATORS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THOSE CRIMES.
IT IS ALSO ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY MORE THAN 40 NATIONS HAVE
COME TOGETHER TO HELP THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
A RIGHT THAT IS ENSHRINED INTO
ARTICLE 51 OF THE NATION'S
CHARTER.
THE MORE SETBACKS RUSSIAN
ENFORCES DUR ON THE BATTLEFIELD,
THE GREATER THE PAIN THEY ARE IN
FL
-- INFLICTING ON UKRAINIANS ON
BRIDGES HOSPITALS AND OTHER
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE ARE A
BRAZEN VIOLATION OF
INTERNATIONAL HUMANITARIAN LAW.
THIS WEEK, PRESIDENT PUTIN SAID
THAT RUSSIA WOULD NOT HESITATE
TO USE AND I QUOTE, ALL WEAPON
SYSTEMS AVAILABLE, END QUOTE.
IN RESPONSE TO A THREAT TO ITS
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY.
A THREAT THAT IS ALL THE MORE
MENACING GIVEN THE ANNEXATION OF
LARGE SWANLS OF UKRAINE AHEAD.
WHEN THAT IS COMPLETE, WE COULD
EXPECT ANY EFFORTS AS AN ATTACK
ON SO-CALLED RUSSIAN TERRITORY.
THIS FROM A COUNTRY THAT IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR IN THIS
PLACE JOINED OTHER PERMANENT
MEMBERS OF THE SECURITY COUNCIL
IN SIGNING A STATEMENT THAT
NUCLEAR WAR COULD NEVER BE WON
AND MUST NEVER BE FOUGHT.
YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HOW
RUSSIA VIOLATES THE COMMITMENTS
ITS MADE BEFORE THIS BODY.
AND YET ANOTHER REASON WHY
NOBODY SHOULD TAKE RUSSIA AT ITS
WORD TODAY.
EVERY COUNCIL MEMBER SHOULD SEND
A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT THESE
RECKLESS NUCLEAR THREATS MUST
STOP IMMEDIATELY.
RUSSIA'S EFFORT TO ANNEX MORE
UKRAINIAN TERRITORY IS A
REPUDIATION OF DIPLOMACY AND
MORE ALARMING WHEN COUPLES WITH
THE FILTRATION OPERATION, THAT
RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE BEEN
CARRYING OUT ACROSS PARTS OF
UKRAINE THAT THEY CONTROL.
NOW, THIS IS A DIE SAW DIA BOLL
STRATEGY.
AND THEY CALL A VOTE AND
MANIPULATE THE RESULTS TO SHOW
NEAR UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR
JOINING THE RUSSIAN FEDERATION.
THIS IS RIGHT OUT OF THE CRIMEA
PLAYBOOK.
AS WITH CRIMEA, IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
COUNCIL AND FOR THAT MATTER
EVERY MEMBER OF THE UNITED
NATIONS REJECT THE SHAM
REFERENDUM AND UNEQUIVOCALLY
DECK CLAIR THAT ALL UKRAINE
TERRITORY IS AND WILL REMAIN
PART OF UKRAINE AND NO RUSSIAN
CLAIM TO ANNEX TERRITORY COULD
TAKE AWAY UKRAINE'S RIGHT TO
DEFEND ITS OWN LAND.
PUTIN'S INVASION IS ALSO
DISTRACTING THIS COUNCIL.
IN FACT, THE ENTIRE U.N. SYSTEM
FROM WORKING ON THE SERIOUS
ISSUES THAT WE ALL WANT TO FOCUS
ON.
LIKE PREVENTING A CLIMATE C
CATASTROPHE, AIDING TENS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ON THE BRINK
OF FAMINE.
FULFILLING THE 2030 AGENDA FOR
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT AND
SHORING UP OUR HEALTH SECURED
AND THAT MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
THE LIVES OF THE CITIZENS THAT
WE'RE HERE TO REPRESENT AND THAT
THEY ARE LOOKING TO US, LOOKING
TO US TO DELIVER ON.
THE WELCOMING MAJORITY OF U.N.
MEMBER STATES ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING TOGETHER ON THESE ISSUES
AND OUR ACTIONS SHOW THAT.
YET, WHILE MORE THAN 100
COUNTRIES HAVE SIGNED ON TO A
ROAD MAP TO PROVIDE FOOD AID TO
THOSE WHO NEED IT, AND PARTNERS
ACROSS, AFRICA, ASIA AND THE
EUROPE ARE WORKING TOGETHER FOR
THE GLOBAL FOOD SYSTEMS AND
RUSSIA FOR MONTHS BLOCKED THE
EXPORT OF UKRAINE GRAIN TO THE
WORLD.
AND RUSSIA CONTINUES TO BOMB AND
SEIZE UKRAINE FARMS AND SILOS
AND LEAD ITS WHEAT FIELDS WITH
LAND MINES AND RAISING COST OF
FOOD FOR PEOPLE EVERYWHERE.
AND WHILE GOVERNMENTS AROUND THE
WORLD ARE TEAMING UP WITH
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS,
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR, WITH
PHILANTHROPIES TO END THIS
PANDEMIC AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE BETTER PREPARED FOR THE
NEXT ONE, RUSSIA IS SPREADING
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION ABOUT W.H.O.
APPROVED VACCINES AND FUELLING
VACCINE HESITANCY TO PUTS PEOPLE
IN ALL OF OUR COUNTRIES AT
GREATER RISK.
HERE IS THE REALITY.
NONE OF US CHOSE THIS WAR.
NOT THE UKRAINIANS WHO KNEW THE
CRUSHING TOLL IT WOULD TAKE.
NOT THE UNITED STATES, WHICH
WARNED THAT IT WAS COMING AND-T
WORKED TO PREVENT IT.
NOT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
COUNTRIES AT THE UNITED NATIONS,
AND NEITHER DID OUR PEOPLE OR
THE PEOPLE OF VIRTUALLY EVERY
U.N. MEMBER STATE, WHO ARE
FEELING THE WAR'S CONSEQUENCES
AND GREATER FOODIN SECURE AND
HIGHER ENERGY PRICES.
NOR DID THE RUSSIAN MOTHERS AND
FATHERS WHOSE CHILDREN ARE BEING
SENT OFF TO FIGHT AND DIE IN
THIS WAR.
OR THE RUSSIAN CITIZENS WHO
CONTINUE TO RISK THEIR FREEDOM
TO PROTEST AGAINST IT.
INCL
INCLUDING THOSE WHO CAME OUT
INTO THE STREETS OF MOSCOW TO
CHANT LET OUR CHILDREN LIVE.
INDEED, IT MUST BE ASKED, HOW
HAS THIS AGGRESSION AGAINST
UKRAINE BY PRESIDENT PUTIN
IMPROVE THE LIVES OR PROSPECTS
OF A SINGLE RUSSIAN CITIZEN.
ONE MAN CHOSE THIS WAR.
ONE MAN CAN END IT.
BECAUSE IF RUSSIA STOPS
FIGHTING, THE WAR ENDS.
IF UKRAINE STOPS FIGHTING,
UKRAINE ENDS.
THAT IS WHY WE WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT UKRAINE AS IT DEFENDS
ITSELF AND STRENGTHEN ITS HAND
TO ACHIEVE A DIPLOMATIC SOLUTION
ON JUST TERMS AT A NEGOTIATING
TABLE.
AS PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAS SAID,
DIPLOMACY IS THE OME WAY TO END
THIS WAR.
BUT DIPLOMACY CANNOT AND MUST BE
NOT USED AS A CUDGEL THAT CUTS
AGAIN THE U.N. CHARTER OR
REWARDED RUSSIA FOR VIOLATING
IT.
PRESIDENT PUTIN IS MAKING HIS
CHOICE.
NOW IT IS UP TO ALL OF OUR
COUNTRIES TO MAKE OURS.
TO TELL PRESIDENT PUTIN TO STOP
THE HORROR THAT HE STARTED.
TELL HIM TO STOP PUTTING HIS
INTERESTS ABOVE THE INTERESTS OF
THE REST OF THE WORLD.
INCLUDING HIS OWN PEOPLE.
TELL THEM TO STOP DEBASING THIS
COUNCIL AND EVERYTHING IT STANDS
FOR.
WE, THE PEOPLE OF UNITED
NATIONS, DETERMINED THAT IS HOW
THE PREAMBLE OF THE U.N. CHARTER
STARTS.
WE THE PEOPLE STILL GET TO
CHOOSE THE FATE OF THIS
INSTITUTION AND OUR WORLD.
THE STAKES ARE CLEAR.
THE CHOICES IS OURS.
LET'S MAKE THE RIGHT CHOICE FOR
THE WORLD THAT WE WANT AND THAT
OUR PEOPLE SO DESPERATELY
DESERVE.
THANK YOU.